wissen sie welches thema ich in unserer
viel zu kurzen sommerpause so gar nicht
vermisst habe war zu einfach drechselt
richtig ja projekt selbstversenkung der
britischen inseln wieder mal eine ihrer
woche in london vor allem für boris
johnson der als neuer britischer
premierminister das königreich
terrorisiert das ist glaube ich nicht
übertrieben
ja ja um mit aller gewalt seinen harten
rexit am 31 oktober durchzudrücken
wollte er mal eben das parlament in
zwangsurlaub schicken also ein nicht
gewählter premier beurlaubt ein
gewähltes unterhaus das jetzt ein gesetz
beschlossen hat diese woche dass johnson
eigentlich zwingt bei der eu um einen
weiteren brechreiz aufschub zu bitten
können sie ausschließen dass sie nach
brüssel gehen und um einen späteren exit
bitten fragte eine reporterin
ja das könne antwortet johnson er würde
lieber tot im graben liegen
vielleicht wäre das ein kompromiss
johnson verlangt bedingungslosen
gehorsam nennt kritiker verräter und hat
deswegen 21 tories aus der fraktion
geschmissen darunter den enkel von
winston churchill
vielleicht hat er den bogen da ein
bisschen überspannt denn wie sich
herausgestellt hat viele briten wollen
doch gar nicht in einer diktatur leben
entsprechend dünnen das nervenkostüm von
bier bizarre beleidigung richtung labour
chef er sei eine big girls raunte
johnson dem oppositionsführer entgegen
die bluse eines dicken mädchens
die bluse eines dicken mädchens klingt
wie ein lied von den flippers ist dieser
typ hier schreckten nicht einmal davor
zurück die arme alte queen mit
reinzuziehen in seinem blöden
machtspiele
es kann doch alles nicht wahr sein
wirklich traurig trotzdem gab es diese
woche natürlich auch schöne momente wie
zum beispiel das gesicht von theresa may
nach johnsons erster parlament in der
lage hier haben sie gesehen und bin ich
je eine schadenfreude nachvollziehen
konnte dann diese boris johnson müssen
wir darauf achten gibt am liebsten denen
ja den exzentrischen clown ja um davon
abzulenken um davon abzulenken wie
brandgefährlich er in wirklichkeit ist
jetzt kriegt er also seinen neuwahlen
und behauptet weiter ganz kurz vor einem
tollen neuen deal mit brüssel zu sein
schade nur dass brüssel davon gar nichts
weiß oder frau merkel übrigens ein ganz
großer fan von johnsons humor wie uns
ihr gesicht verrät wie in der uk und die
musik die wir schaffen
man sieht richtig wie sie denkt clotilde
blondine beute kriegs herr johnson hat
keinen plan b zum harten braig cit null
plan und er verrät auch kein wie das
eigentlich gehen soll die zollunion
verlassen aber ohne grenzkontrollen in
irland nicht geht gut das sind so
langweilige detailfragen sowas spielt in
seinem wahlkampf keine rolle
wir schalten live nach london zu tina
hausten die offenbar ein bisschen von
ihrer journalistischen neutralität
eingebüßt hat hessen china
[Musik]
ich bin gern auf die seite von gesegelt
klar sieht der buch ist aus als sei der
versuch eines irren wissenschaftlers
donald trump zyklon auf tragische weise
schief gegangen aber in sachen
propaganda macht ihm keiner was vor
während sich diese woche alle über sein
diktator gehabe aufregen holt boris
einen süßen hund aus dem tierheim
der hund ist einen 15 wochen junge jack
russel den johnson weil sich aufnimmt
hier gibt es bereits ein haustier kater
larry noch ist nicht klar ob sich die
beiden vertragen
er hat kater larry nach zehn minuten tot
gebissen
boris johnson dieser entertainment gott
beweist in der modernen politik kannst
du dein leben lang lügen dass sich die
balken biegen
selbst pinocchio würde sagen alter das
kannst du so nicht bringen
aber so hat hauptsache du bist nie
langweilig ich weiß nicht ab und zu mal
fakten finde ich der politik gar nicht
so schlecht ja weil sie alt sind
boris johnson hat schon als junger
journalist in brüssel bewusst die
wahrheit ist letztlich auch nur ein
unverbindlicher vorschlag schrieb
geschichten die nur sehr entfernt etwas
mit der wahrheit zu tun haben zum
beispiel wie europa versucht
großbritannien standardgrößen für
kondome aufzuzwingen oder entschieden
habe dass schnecken fische seien daher
auch der alte witz kommt ein blinder im
fischladen und sagt hallo schnecken ja
naja jedenfalls der abschied von den
fakten es nicht ganz neue möglichkeiten
noch im august hat johnson gesagt er
wird das parlament auf keinen fall in
zwangsurlaub schicken während er daran
gearbeitet hat das parlament in
zwangsurlaub zu schicken
was ist denn daran toll das ist total
befreiend ja auch für uns journalisten
früher musste ich alles recherchieren
was ich ihr lover und jetzt kann ich mir
einfach irgendetwas ausdenken was weiß
ich
skandal boris johnson lässt sich auf
kosten der britischen krankenkasse die
brüste vergrößern oder boris johnson hat
eine affäre mit schönster
und traurig in seiner freizeit bricht
boris johnson gerne achtjährigen die
beine
naja ich fange journalismus früher auch
besser
oliver ja ich höre gerade die bbc sendet
live aus dem garten von downing street
an boris johnsons hund gibt seine erste
pressekonferenz
[Applaus]
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show you tube kanal als
begeistern schließt gefälligst ein abo
ab sofort